[Musik]
die meerenge von kertsch nadel krim am
25 november 2008 10 rammt die russische
küstenwache drei ukrainische
marineschiffe ein vorläufiger höhepunkt
in der auseinandersetzung beider länder
und ein zeichen für die zunehmende
aggression die zum krieg im jahr 2022
führt vor dem angriffskrieg russlands
gegen die ukraine nehmen die spannungen
jahrelang zu der militärischen
eskalation geht an energie krieg voraus
der grund seit den 1970 er jahren dient
die ukraine mit der gaspipeline transgas
als transitland für russisches gas nach
mitteleuropa
die durchleitungsgebühren sind ein
wesentlicher teil des staatshaushalts
der ukraine nach dem jahr 1990 und dem
ende der sowjetunion entbrennt ein
heftiger streit um die
durchleitungsgebühren russland sucht
nach alternativen routen das gas
hungrige deutschland bekommt mit der
hoch umstrittenen nord stream 1 pipeline
in der ostsee günstiges erdgas weit weg
von der ukraine
bereits in nord stream 1 war umstritten
der russische präsident putin und
kanzler schröder verteidigten die
partner im jahr 2004 gegen kritik schon
damals sprachen kritiker von einer
abhängigkeit die entstehe
wladimir putin dazu fragen sie doch bei
den unternehmen und bieten pipeline
vertrag unterzeichnen ob die
zusammenarbeit nötig ist sie werden ja
sagen und das und kaum aus
innenpolitischen gründen
bei der vertragsunterzeichnung im juli
2004 waren auch die deutschen firmen
wintershall und e.on mit von der partie
jan schröder bestritten nachteile für
andere länder diese zusammenarbeit ist
gegen niemanden gerichtet sondern dient
deutschen interessen und dient
russischen interesse und ich wüsste
nicht was daran falsch sein sollte warum
ist die geopolitische rolle von nord
stream eins und zwei so unterschätzt
worden aus russischer sicht war es von
beginn an ein geostrategisches projekt
es ging darum europa abhängig zu machen
das lässt sich zurückverfolgen
diese idee bis in die rede von wladimir
putin vor dem deutschen bundestag 2001
oder die rede die er vor der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz 2007 gehalten hat
es ging immer darum eine
weltmacht russland zu aufzubauen die
eben den amerikanern paroli bieten kann
und dazu musste der politisch
bestimmender einfluss russlands über
europa hergestellt werden weil russland
alleine wieder demografisch noch
wirtschaftlich in der lage ist mit
den usa und inzwischen auch china auf
augenhöhe
internationale probleme zu besprechen
die geopolitische rolle der parkplatz
vor allem der neuen nord stream zwei
sehen die usa von beginn an und
bekämpfen das projekt egal wer im weißen
haus sitzt die verlegung der rohre
verzögert sich durch sanktionen der usa
immer wieder joe biden beendet dann den
jahrelangen streit zwischen deutschland
und den usa mit einem machtwort am 8
februar
wenn russland
eindringt in die ukraine den also panzer
und soldaten die ukrainische grenze
überschreiten einer mehr
dann wird es kein nord stream zwei
projekt mehr geben dann ist schluss
damit der hafen lubmin in mecklenburg
vorpommern hier liegt das deutsche
anteil der nord stream 2 fertiggestellt
doch durch den kriegsbeginn stream 2
endgültig geschichte das projekt dürfte
am ende über elf milliarden euro
gekostet haben die muttergesellschaft
des projekts die russische gazprom lässt
die schweizerische nord stream 2 am ende
in die pleite rutschen nun fließt nur
durch noch stream 1 gas den westen
rückblick september 2009 10
die
solitaire
die kosten verlegeschiffe für beide
bleibt auf der welt
die solitaire wollen wir besuchen um zu
schauen wie geht die aber dann noch zwei
der umstrittenen pipeline vorrat hier 45
minuten flug südlich der schwedischen
insel gotland verlegt die mannschaft auf
dem rund 300 meter langen spezialschiffs
die gaspipeline und kämpft um die zeit
denn bis ende 2019 soll die neue
verbindung zwischen russland und
deutschland fertig sein auf dem lande
deck erwartet und sicherheitspersonal
das auch bei schwierigsten
wetterverhältnissen die landung
absichert das heißt bei einem orkan bei
windstärke 11 hohem wellengang und
schlechter sicht müssen
versorgungsschiffe passen die
hubschrauber fliegen dann immer noch
weiter von oben ist gut erkennbar dass
die solitaire eine schwimmende fabrik
ist die sicherheitsanforderungen für die
besatzung sind sehr hoch auch für uns
diese energieversorgung europas
verändert sich durch nord stream 2 die
zweite große erdgaspipeline nach nord
stream 1 die im november 2011 eingeweiht
wurde das ruft die politik auf den plan
us-präsident trump lässt keine
gelegenheit aus das projekt massiv zu
kritisieren für ihn entsteht durch nord
stream eine hohe abhängigkeit europas
von russischen gas mit deutschland geht
er dabei besonders hart ins gericht im
juli 2018 klagt er deutschland wird
total von russland kontrolliert die
bekommen 60 bis 70 prozent ihrer energie
aus russland und dieser neuen pipeline
wir müssen über die milliarden und
abermilliarden reden die die deutschen
an ein land zahlen gegen dass wir die
amerikaner sie schützen sollen doch auch
in europa und anliegenden nachbarländern
bleibt die pipeline bei einigen ein
rotes tuch
stream 2
nutzt deutschland nicht jedenfalls nicht
in puncto energie sicherheit es hilft
der eu nicht und auch nicht der ukraine
wer soll denn nun wirklich interesse
daran
die meinungen in der europäischen
metropole brüssel gehen weit auseinander
zumal hinter nord stream die quasi
staatliche russische gazprom besteht sie
setzt sich massiv in den europäischen
institutionen für das projekt erhalten
für die kanzlerin gehört die fahrplan
zur energiewende
ich weiß jetzt meine freunde in der svp
sind über nord stream alles andere als
einer meinung aber wir werden wenn wir
aus der kohle aussteigen wollen mehr gas
benutzen müssen noch für eine brücken
zeit und das bedeutet war werden wir
russland als quelle nicht ausschließen
auf dem pipeline verleger solitär wird
in drei schichten gearbeitet
im rennen gegen die kommenden
herbststürme aber auch gegen die
angedrohten sanktionen der usa die die
besitzer des schiffes treffen die
gesellschaft und sie sitzt in der
schweiz aber sanktionen können die
zufahrt in us häfen unterbinden
internationalen zahlungsverkehr und die
zusammenarbeit mit amerikanischen firmen
für die bedeutende pipeline verleger
firma acs würde dies das aus bedeuten
und der politische druck aus den usa
wird im jahr 2019 immer stärker
tatsächlich erhält der holländische
kapitän kenny hoben einen anruf von der
zentrale in der schweiz die arbeit von
acs wird sofort beendet die pipeline
verlegung liegt stehen die proteste
gegen den bau der pipeline werden noch
massiver senatoren drängen auf einen
stopp besonders senator ted hughes aus
texas seine haltung wird von vielen als
unterstützung der eigenen gasförderung
in texas interpretiert die kanzlerin
widerspricht den forderungen
ich sage heute dass die
sanktionen ja sowieso noch mal wieder
verstärkt werden aber dass ich mir eine
grundeinstellung noch nicht dahingehend
verändert hat dass ich sage das projekt
soll es nicht geben die usa erweitern
die sanktionen auch auf firmen die nur
mittelbar mit dem bau der pipeline zu
tun haben der weiterbau von nord stream
2 erscheint ungewiss
es ging
wenn man sich die reden von barack obama
von donald trump anhört wirklich darum
die energieabhängigkeit zu reduzieren
also nicht zu sagen europa soll kein gas
und kein öl keine kohle in russland
einkaufen das war ja gar nicht das ziel
das ziel war es auf ein maß zu
beschränken indem eben diese
abhängigkeit nicht besteht und da hat
man dann nach 2020 wirklich zu dem
mittel von sanktionen gegriffen und
deutschland hat dann in der phase das
gemacht was es etwa auch bei den
iran-sanktionen gemacht hat das hat
versucht das ganze zu umgehen die
sanktionen der usa treffen das projekt
und stellen die gesamte pipeline in
frage mehrere senatoren schreiben in
einem brief unverhohlen man werde durch
die sanktionen auch einen deutschen
hafen wirtschaftlich zerstören dort soll
nämlich ein russisches schiff den
weiterbau möglich machen nachdem es für
enorme summen zum pipeline verleger
umgebaut ist in mukran dem hafen von
sassnitz auf der insel rügen liegt die
akademie kerski sie wird dort umgebaut
und beginnt im märz 2021 die pipeline
nord stream zwei weiterzubauen das
schiff lässt sich nicht sanktionieren
wohl aber der hafen mukran und die stadt
sassnitz
hinter mir liegt die akademie kerski ein
russisches verlegeschiff was eigentlich
in wladiwostok liegt über 11.000
kilometer luftlinie von hier entfernt
sie ersetzt die solitaire
ist der weiterbau durch den umbau eines
ganzen schiffes überhaupt wirtschaftlich
das scheint gazprom nicht zu
interessieren das projekt ist ein
politisches symbol für die
ministerpräsidenten von mecklenburg
vorpommern kommt ein stopp nicht in
frage
egal wie man es nord stream 2 steht es
ist ein recht staatlich genehmigtes
projekt
und deshalb dürfen nicht die betriebe
die an diesem projekt arbeiten wie der
hafen mukran hier bedroht oder
sanktioniert werden und das schon gar
nicht passieren kann ist dass dieser
hafen mukran der kleine hafen mukran und
vor allem seine mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter spielball von
weltpolitischen interessen wird die
region braucht das projekt dringend denn
jeder arbeitsplatz zählt in der
wirtschaftlich schwachen region schon
die einrichtung einer täglichen
fährverbindungen nach schweden hat kraft
und nerven gekostet ist aber enorm
wichtig um zahlungskräftige schweden zum
tages trip nach sassnitz zu holen die
nerven liegen blank mich ärgert ton und
form des umgangs ich glaube dass das
unterländer die jeweils die souveränität
des anderen respektieren sich nicht
gehört was da passiert aber losgelöst
davon unser schmerz ist vor einigen dass
diese sanktions androhung das ist
eigentlich das perfide an dieser politik
eher so eine art geiselnahme von ganz
viel angst der beteiligten versuchen in
dem alle e wie sorge arm ist könnte was
passieren und sich deshalb zurückziehen
oder besser zurückhalten zurückhaltender
werden in der region geht angesichts der
sanktionsdrohungen die angst um die
rohre stapeln sich zu dieser zeit im
hafen und warten auf die verlegung
selbstverständlich ist es so dass wir
auch in der vergangenheit auch aus einem
reinen fährhafen einen multifunktions
hafen gestaltet haben und auch sehr
viele arbeitsplätze entstanden sind bei
uns und es ist sehr wichtig für die
insel rügen für die stadt sachsens dass
solche
die arbeitsplätze auch weiterhin
erhalten bleiben und auch neue dazu
kommen weil nur von tourismus kann man
aus meiner sicht nicht leben was
passiert wenn die sanktionen doch kommen
wir sind in einer globalen welt die
reederei die heute mit uns den katamaran
als erstes auf die reise geschickt hat
ist zum beispiel auch in amerika tätig
und die gefahr besteht ich hoffe dass
unsere bundesregierung erschafft solch
eine sanktion abzuwenden damit wir uns
mit solchen problemen nicht beschäftigen
brauchen die ministerpräsidentin
ortsbesuch hier ist der endpunkt der
pipeline lubmin und die region würden
von nord stream zwei stark profitieren
manuela schwesig will das projekt
durchziehen der anti sanktions trick
lautet klimastiftung denn eine stiftung
mit nord stream 2 im boot kann nicht
sanktioniert werden und so kommt es dass
die landesregierung mit noch zu drehen
zwei zusammen eine stiftung gründet und
unverhohlen klimaschutz und den
weiterbau der pipeline verbindet im
landtag kommt sie damit durch denn allen
ist hier bewusst nur mit diesem trick
lässt sich das sanktions drama umgehen
im bundestag gehen die meinungen weit
auseinander
manuela schwesig kontert selbst
parteigenossen in allererster linie
werden wir eine gute stiftung haben mit
der wir unser großes thema umwelt und
klimaschutz im land voranbringen können
und wenn es nötig ist kann die stiftung
einen kleinen beitrag zur ostseepipeline
leisten 99% des satzungs textes gehen um
umwelt und klima aber 99 prozent des
geldes kommen von gazprom das ist keine
umweltstiftung das ist eine gazprom
stiftung im grunde eine
terrororganisation die frau schwesig da
gegründet hat im bundestag ist das thema
nord stream lange ein zankapfel quer
durch alle parteien
gegner und befürworter stehen sich
unversöhnlich gegenüber
am ende der diskussion steht
pragmatismus selbst gegner das projekt
befürworten im jahr 2021 die
fertigstellung der pipeline wohl vor
allem um das thema endlich vom tisch zu
haben wir besuchen 2009 10 die baustelle
in russland
hier beginnt noch zwei im
nordwestrussischen zehn fußballfelder
groß ist das gewirr aus rohren
verbindungsstücken ventilen und
verdichtern das gas das hier ankommt hat
bereits eine lange strecke hinter sich
die rund zweieinhalb stunden von sankt
petersburg entfernt geht das gas was aus
libyen kommt über 3000 kilometer
unterwegs ist quasi in die pipeline nord
stream 2 in die ostsee hinein und dann
sind es noch einmal 1230 kilometer bis
lubmin in mecklenburg vorpommern
dort wo das gas in deutschland ankommt
das ankommende gas wird durch ein gewirr
von rohren geleitet und nach dem weg aus
sibirien unter hohem druck auf die reise
in die ostsee pipeline gepresst dinara
bucht ist 1230 kilometer von zielhafen
entfernt und die 800 arbeiter und
ingenieure vor ort kommen aus vielen
verschiedenen ländern vor allem
holländische und skandinavische firmen
beteiligen sich am bau ihre erfahrungen
beim thema gas sind weltweit gefragt
die anrainerstaaten der beiden parkplatz
haben den baum misstrauisch bis
ablehnend beäugt das war schon bei
nordstream einst so die direkte
verlegung durch die ostsee kennt nur
zwei profiteure deutschland und russland
hartnäckiger widerstand kommt vor allem
aus den baltischen staaten und aus polen
und natürlich besonders aus der ukraine
von beginn an der planung ist
offensichtlich dass nun mitten durch die
ostsee eine konkurrenz zur pipeline
durch das eigene land entsteht das
misstrauen gegenüber den feindlichen
russland ist groß die
durchleitungsgebühren stehen auf dem
spiel beim besuch der deutschen
kanzlerin in liter und war noch stream
zwei zentrales thema litauen lehnt die
pipeline rundweg ab die kanzlerin hält
dagegen
angesichts der ziele die wir im
zusammenhang mit der klimapolitik
erreichen müssen werden wir auch unseren
erdgasbedarf er vergrößern das north
stream zwei projekt ist deshalb eines
was ich für sinnvoll halte litauens
präsidentin grybauskaite
wir sehen es als geopolitisches und
nicht als wirtschaftspolitisches projekt
auch nicht als energieprojekt unsere
position hat damit zu tun dass wir
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht haben wir
wissen was es bedeutet wenn man von
einem einzigen energielieferanten
abhängt der russland heißt
aufnahmen der überwachungskamera an bord
eines russischen versorgungsschiff in
der ostsee am 20 februar 2021 um 433
morgens rammt ein polnisches fischerboot
dieses begleitschiff der russischen
fortuna die verlegt die pipeline nord
stream 2 ein unfall oder eine attacke
die von der russischen
nachrichtenagentur ria novosti
veröffentlichte bilder zeigen auch
überflüge polnische militärflugzeuge die
in geringer höhe offenbar die verlegung
der gasrohre der fahrplan beobachten
immer wieder tauchen flugzeuge oder auch
schiffe in der nähe der verlegung auf
ein zufall wohl kaum denn im erbitterten
streit um die partner noch zudem zwei
wird mit harten bandagen gekämpft und
polen gehört zu den gegner des projekts
die anrainer staaten und polen fürchten
mit dem bau stelle sich eine
verschiebung der machtverhältnisse bei
der energie her die ukraine fürchtet
noch mehr sie erhält pro jahr zwei
milliarden dollar staatseinnahmen für
die durchleitung des gases das nun in
der ostsee fließt und sie von den
einnahmen abschneiden könnte vertreter
von nord stream 2 allerdings behaupten
von anfang an die ukraine werde nach dem
bau von nord stream 24 berücksichtigt
und müsse keine nachteile befürchten
das war auch eine so wie ich es
verstanden habe eine der
grundbedingungen für dieses projekt das
es für die ukraine eine lösung gibt das
auch weiterhin dort transit stattfinden
wird und wenn wir uns vor augen führen
dass wir den nächsten ungefähr zwölf bis
15 jahren in europa mindestens 25 des
energieverbrauches nicht gedeckt haben
der muss durch importe gedeckt werden
und hier wird nord stream ungefähr 55
milliarden kubikmeter was ungefähr der
energieversorgung von 26 millionen
haushalten entspricht beitragen können
das heißt 70 bis 80 milliarden
kubikmeter müssen irgendwo herkommen und
die reine mathematik spricht dafür dass
auch die ukraine weiterhin einen
transitkorridor nach europa sein wird
eine alternative zur pipeline gas
unterstützen die gegner noch streams
besonders flüssiggas das tankschiffe
befördern größter profiteur die usa
bisher von flüssiggas lng genannt vor
allem aus norwegen und holland aber die
usa befördern seit jahren über fracking
enorme mengen konnten den verkauf in
europa um zuletzt 270 prozent steigern
angebote aus dem mittleren osten und
afrika kommen hinzu ist das argument
einer abhängigkeit von russland damit
vom tisch nord stream meint ja
das ist die frage was der markt hergibt
und es ist auch die frage wieviel
hersteller von bestimmten und
lieferanten sie von bestimmten dingen
brauchen es kommt auch keiner in
deutschland auf die frage brauchen wir
nur eine autohersteller wollen wir nur
eine autotypen es ist der markt der
entscheiden wird woher das gas kommt und
da werden die russen mit sicherheit
einen signifikanten anteil haben an den
liefermengen die nach europa kommen aber
es werden auch signifikante mengen
energie aus afrika aus arabischen
halbinsel oder aus den usa nach europa
strömen am ende ist es alles eine frage
des preises was ist der deutsche was der
europäische kunde bereit für energie zu
bezahlen und dann wird sich entscheiden
woher das gas kommt in der deutschen
innenpolitik flammt die diskussion um
die abhängigkeit vom russischen gas
immer wieder auf vor allem um die
interessen der ukraine zu unterstützen
wir haben schon mehrmals erlebt dass die
russen mitten im winter bei minus 25
grad kälte den gashahn gedreht haben und
die gas lieferungen gestoppt haben seit
50 jahren liefern wie erdgas nach europa
und wir haben nie einen anlass gegeben
dass irgendwelche vorfälle passieren
heute ist allen klar nord stream war ein
über zwei jahrzehnte geplantes projekt
das vor allem deutschland in eine
gefährliche abhängigkeit von russischem
gas gebracht hat trotzdem zwei da keine
betriebsgenehmigung bekommen auch die
anderen wege von russland eben energie
nach europa zu liefern werden
unterbunden werden denn inzwischen geht
es nicht mehr darum nord stream 2 zu
verhindern sondern sich vollständig von
energielieferungen aus russland
unabhängig zu machen weil sie eben mit
politischen zwecken eingesetzt wurden
man hat erkannt im zuge des krieges
gegen die ukraine dass es nicht
geschäftliche verbindungen sind sondern
dass mit dem gas politische erpressung
erfolgt und davon gilt dass sich
freizumachen eine abhängigkeit die lange
verleugnet wurde bis zuletzt spd
spitzenkandidat scholz bestritten auch
im wahlkampf
2021 diese gefahr und widersprach den
sorgen der usa es gibt in den usa die
falsche vorstellung dass wir sehr
abhängig wären von diesem russischen gaz
das ist aber wenn man den energiemix in
deutschland insgesamt betrachtet nicht
richtig und dazu beizutragen dass diese
wahrnehmung korrigiert werden kann das
war eine richtige aufgabe der
bundesregierung die hat sie auch
wahrgenommen
ich finde wir sollten jetzt ganz ganz
konkret sein dass es jetzt hier darum
geht die gelegenheiten zu nutzen für
eine gute kooperation um diese zu einem
ende zu führen dass auch das will ich
ganz ausdrücklich sagen für die
amerikanische politik zufriedenstellend
ist
gehört für mich ausdrücklich dazu dass
die sicherheit zum beispiel der ukraine
die ja auch von den einnahmen aus dem
gastransit abhängig ist dabei immer
gewährleistet wird plötzlich stehen also
die zeichen auf rückzug besonders
politisch verantwortliche im bundesland
mecklenburg vorpommern waren immer um
kontakte zu russland bemüht
unterstützten den bau von nord stream
zwei bis hin zur juristisch fragwürdigen
umgehung der sanktionen über die
umweltstiftung manuela schwesig
verteidigt sich unverdrossen natürlich
ist es ganz normal dass man wenn man
einen solchen infrastruktur projekt
arbeitet dann auch mit dem unternehmen
spricht und vor allem auf die interessen
des landes schaut es ging um
arbeitsplätze im unternehmen
es ging auch um die sanktion die
interessen des landes die grünen im
landtag verlangen aufklärung wie weit
war das vorgehen rechtmäßig und welche
interessen des landes hat es gestartet
das überprüft nun ein
untersuchungsausschuss im schweriner
landtag
es verdichtet sich ja immer mehr das der
eigentliche zweck der stiftungsgründung
die sind fertig bau der pipeline gewesen
ist und das andere nur ein feigenblatt
zur durchsetzung genau dieser dieses
pipeline aus und heute das paar plant
schiff solitär verlegt längst rohre vor
der südküste der usa die russische
akademie kerski liegt vor der halbinsel
von sachalin und die paar plan sie liegt
wie nord stream 1 in der ostsee gefüllt
mit gas was damit geschieht ist völlig
unklar unklar auch wenn die rohre wartet
und überprüft was angesichts der
sensiblen umwelt in der ostsee heikel
ist die bundesregierung soll schon eine
enteignung des deutschen teils erwägen
die partnern könnte dann an flüssiggas
terminals angeschlossen werden das wird
so sein dass am ende europa unabhängiger
sein wird von energie die von außen
importiert wird und russland wird der
große verlierer dabei sein es war eine
fehlkalkulation von präsident putin dass
er dachte die europäer sind so
zerstritten die europäer sind so
abhängig von unseren gaslieferung dass
sie die ukraine nicht unterstützen
werden das zusammen mit einer schnellen
machtübernahme in kiew so wie sie
geplant war hätten eine ganz andere
situation gestaltet da hat sich wenn sie
denn putin völlig verschätzt im
rückblick auf den politischen streit um
die projekte nord stream 1 und 2 müssen
sich die befürworter fragen gefallen
lassen sind sie der illusion vom rein
wirtschaftlichen zweck erlegen war es
ein fall von selbsttäuschung jetzt wo
die gasversorgung aus russland in frage
steht war es ein kapitales politisches
versagen